individual examples including embryology
that way both of our audiences will know
you know where we stand on the issues
yeah how does that sound that sounds
fine all right so what I wanted to say
first and foremost is that we and I
think maybe you'll agree with me here we
don't say that science is encourageable
or that it produces Eternal sets of
Truth and we know that the scientific
method is based on falsification as K
POA and others have stipulated and as
such their can be change in science even
that which is referred to as scientific
fact we know that Thomas [__] wrote a
book called the structures of Scientific
Revolution yep which talks about what he
refers to as Paradigm Shift yeah I've
got it you've got that book got that
book so me and you I think both agree
that we shouldn't be using
science as a yard stick for truth in an
absolute sense because maybe me and you
will agree that science is itself not a
perfect or Eternal encourageable
Enterprise would you agree with that can
I reply yes of course so I agree with
the general thesis laid out by Muhammad
I agree with it however there are
relative truths within greater paradigms
that we can establish as certain things
that we have no reason to indicate
because until there is a greater degree
of observational
tool as well as the fact that technology
itself will reach a limit in terms of
What observations it can make will mean
that there is a
water H2O all right so I in a sense I
kind of do agree with you but I'd like
to kind of couch my language in more
specific and sophisticated terminology
on I think you're right to say that
there's different epistemic weights to
different observations that one can have
scientifically yeah but I would I would
use it on a scale of probability so is
exactly what science does yeah exactly
so for instance like if I
say that men have XY chromosomes and
women have XX chromosomes that to me
seems a more certain fact than string
theory for instance because string
theory was is new it hasn't had the same
the same kind
of um kind of peer-reviewed exposure as
has you know the biological
understanding of XY versus XX I think I
think me and you have got enough grasp
of the scientific method to to now move
the conversation forward so yeah so so
that's good so what we're saying is
effectively we agree on the fact that
science is not an eternal truth but that
certain things are probabilistically
more possible than others yes and that
some observations we have no grounds to
dispute would you agree with that that
certain observations within science yeah
I would agree with that right and and
that that so for instance like the XY
and xx well I mean it's a bit more
complicated than that because there's XX
Y and there's x y y no no but yeah yeah
these are additions rather than
replacements for
yeah exactly so so they work within a
certain Paradigm so now here here's let
let me lay out my case yeah cuz I'm the
prosecutor in this discussion now we are
both prosecutors and we're both
defendants right well let me let me let
me we we we talked about the fact that
yeah yeah yeah we're going to bring both
of the book yes that's absolutely fine
that's absolutely fine so in terms of
the standard so I'm going to lay out my
case in terms of the standard that the
Quran lays out for itself
it says in Surah 482 you probably know
it off the top of your head what does he
say if it was from mother than God they
would have found in it many
inconsistencies yeah exactly many yeah
and I I'll just I'll just read it um in
the translation that we've got here as
well yes so just to make sure that
there's no dispute
for do they do they not consider the
Quran care
had it been from other than Allah they
would surely have found therein many a
contradiction now many a contradiction
can be internal contradictions or it can
be external contradictions agreed yes
so Muslims have marshaled and I accuse
the the the da those who are doing da I
accuse them of lying deliberately okay
because they claim and I'm going to
demonstrate that is
false the the Quran when you say they
let's be clear here the on let's be
let's be very specific because people
like Zaki Knight people like people like
Adnan Rashid people like I've given I've
given you some examples shab but are you
talking about Zaki and Nike or are you
talking because you have to understand
something I I think it's very important
to realize that we don't all have the
same view when it comes to this I agree
so so so it's not I don't think it's
very clever to generalize the specific I
did say the those doing da and I gave
examples people that I'm talking that's
why I just had to interrupt to make sure
that that kind of specificity was
ensured okay so so we' we've clarified
that so now in terms of the the the
argument you like that yeah in terms of
the
argument no no no it's it's it's to
totally fine he said it's totally fine
in terms of in terms of the
argument in terms of the argument yes
sir Muslims make the argument that the
Quran accurately describes
embryology that that's what they say now
I'm talking I've qualified that so when
I say Muslims I'm speaking about certain
kinds of Muslims like Rashid like Zak
like shab Ali not every Muslim I I fully
appreciate that
so it is fair therefore for me to test
that argument of course right so when I
look at the description in the Quran and
I'm going to read it to you I'm going to
ask you to to just just qualify for me
what you think the stages are that are
being described so if we go to Surah
2312 yeah I got it yeah y so 12 to 14 if
you want to recite that while I'm
getting out the English no it's fine you
can just go ahead okay fair enough yeah
but but but just before I do recite it
if you want me to there are there are
two sp there are it's not just 23 which
talks about stages there's 22 as
well I've got that yeah so what you want
me to go through all the stages no no no
I'm going to read it and when you hear a
stage I want you to stop me interrupt me
and say this is a stage is that fair so
so that everyone can hear the case being
made out right right so and indeed we
created man out of an extract of clay
thereafter we made him as a n n n thank
you H in a safe lodging then we made the
NFTA nuta into a cloth then we made the
into a clot then we made the clot into a
little lump of Flesh then we made out of
that little lump of Flesh bones then we
clothed the bones with flesh and then we
brought it forth as another creation so
how many stages did you hear there in
this
part number one what sorry so the clay
or mud so clay y all right and then you
have
um we made him into a n in a safe
lodging so n
the same is the safe
Ling so you hear three stages no no so
um so no no no you got you got you got
so let's go with yeah we talk about
embryology in particular right so if you
have n yeah then you have mud which is
mud is a lump and in by the way on this
no no no just just going through the
Stag I have to no I'm doing it but you
have to let me say what what it is yeah
in chapter 22 it says
about so it's partly formed and partly
unformed yeah yeah and then so after M
you have which is a claw and then after
you
have which is Bones yeah and then you
have after that uh flesh okay so five
now again just like the Muslim brother
before him without any prompting from me
no prompting from me at all Muhammad
said you have bones then flesh yeah so
that's two Muslims independently and
hijab is an experienced debater who said
bones and then flesh that's right now
guys it is a simple fact of embryology
and you can all go and Google it right
now bones do
not now notice the interruptions notice
the interruptions guys let him make his
claim please let him make his by man
man do you not think that hijab is big
enough to stick up for
himself I don't think hijab needs your
help if you want to come into the bit
stand
there here why you off no no no I'm
going to correct him every now and then
hurry on right so guys I challenge you
now now to go away and research it
yourself no embryologist argues that
bones become flesh not anyone that is
respectable except man except Mansour ex
man so so so sadly this is why I have to
raise my voice I didn't want to but I'm
going to have to I'm going to have to
raise my voice because of man saw it's a
shame because me and hijab were having a
nice conversation until until mansur
turned
up so I'm not I'm not all you're doing
is delaying the argument I'm still going
to say my point man so I'm waiting I'm
waiting for him to sh I'm waiting for
you made your point I haven't finished
my point I haven't made my point all
right guys be quiet please let him
finish his point because we have nothing
to hide here have nothing to hide here
let him finish his point he said there's
no references we're going to we're going
to just explore that so the fact of the
matter is without any prompting from me
hijab has said bones then flesh and it
is a fact ladies and gentlemen a fact
that you can check for
yourselves that bones and flesh grow
together JC Focus no they don't okay
they grow together they grow at the same
time guys guys down they grow at the
same time down from the mess come down
yes yes so when the Quran says that both
grow with flesh it's wrong for two
reasons yes sir go ahead firstly there
is no OIC at this point it's cartilage
it's not
bonification comes later that's actually
false comes later and it isn't that the
bones grow independently from the flesh
by the way they grow together are you
interrupting they grow together and this
is why the Quran is wrong because it
stages it and he admitted it bones than
flesh your response okay he said there's
no oifc OIC is when bone forms and this
is also referred to as osteogenesis okay
he also said bones than flesh now let's
be very clear the word bones in Arabic
is now the the word in the a was the
word in the Arabic language includes
cartilage by the way how do we know that
if you look at the the Arabic
lexicons and I can give you the names of
them if you like I'd like you to pull it
up show us from yeah no can you pull it
up can we see it yeah yeah I can yeah
uh so for example I'll tell you I'll
read it exactly as it says in the
Lexicon right so basically this is what
man says in his lexicon the Arabic aladi
mentions aladi is another Arabic lexicon
okay and this is he died
817 guys please I'm I'm quoting it I'm
quoting it I'm quoting it by the word so
there's no one here going to say get me
a reference I'm quoting it he
says yeah and this is in I'll tell you
exactly where it is it is
in uh volume one page
840 any any issues so yes I have an
issue okay no no let me finish
but I have an issue now now that we have
established have we not you with
references have we not that which is
cartilage is bone and cartilage can be
used synonymously he said that oifc
doesn't happen that's absolutely absurd
no I didn't say no he did say at this
point he did say that
didn't heard now he's making scientific
mistakes he said there's no reference as
well all right so excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me he
said calm down because he's saying that
there's no reference I've got a book
called The fundamentals of human
embryology be quiet please the
fundamentals of human embryology printed
where please yeah okay I tell you page
148 this is a book that is used uh by
biologists in in their first or second
year and this is also a book that is
used by medical students and others it's
it's a book called The fundamentals of
human embryology we'll look at it it
might be Oxford University press I'm not
going to give you like a full
bibliography now you're being a bit
ridiculous now page 148 I give you that
one I you that one all right look page
148 listen to what it said soon after
the cartilagenous models of the bones
have been established the myogenic cells
which have now become myoblasts
aggregate to form muscle masses on the
ventral and dorsal aspects of the limbs
these muscle masses in the relevant
compartments form the flexors and
extensors of the joints Rotator muscles
are also form form so that flexors and
protator and pronators are related and
extenders are uh and supernat are
related now this is very very clear to
me and it's actually a reference no let
me no let me just no no no please when
somebody who's not he's a lay man when
it comes to science and he a lay man
when it comes to philosophy and he's a
lay man when it comes to Islamic
Theology and he's a lay man when it
comes to the Arabic language has the
audacity to come and stand wait excuse
me calm down calm down Cal down has the
audacity to come in front of no no no
let me finish has the audacity to come
in front of me making two false claims
the first of which is that the
Quran has said come on let me finish let
me finish going
at he made he said it on the camera he
said it on the camera he said it on the
camera and this is the age of Technology
he said artification doesn't happen at
this stage that's false that is false
osteogenesis he did say that well we can
rewind it we can rewind it excuse me
horific does take place by the admission
of the authorities and that's what
people are using in universities all
across this country number two no no
number two excuse me let me finish I
gave you number two why you saying
number number two you're going on too
long this is why we need to do it time
this is why we need to do it let me
finish this point no then you can do it
time but I'm just making one more point
and then you can say what you like
number
two is the only interpretation in the
Quran that the fa is chronological or
meaning is it chronological no there are
two interpretations in the Islamic
understanding one of them is that it is
chronological and the other one is that
it's not chronological andab
he takes the view that all of it happens
in the first 40 days and the he mentions
that in his of the of in
the
sorry and then he says and then because
you know excuse me hold on no no hold on
hold on this Hadith says and and let me
finish let me finish let me finish let
me finish let me finish
let me finish let
meish let me finish let me finish you
need to hear all the data otherwise you
won't know what going on let me finish
you're not finishing let meish you're
not finishing though give me what not
finishing let me finish H know there's
another way of the
Hadith listen please calm down please he
said in the there's another Hadith very
important this is very important so he
said said that in theith of Muslim and
the listen the of Muslim
it's which means in that time listen it
means in that time it will be like that
so because it
said the opinion of the and the Mata the
hes is that it all happens in 40 days
why is it there for that there's a
difference of opinion among the when
just making another point please man
stop st let
me
let me let me finish let meish you're
not finishing let me finish not finish
let me
finish finish you're not finish but
you're not finish I'm going to finish no
you're not though you're going to make
Point let me finish that's why that's
why the F have differed the jurists have
differed as to when a woman can have an
abortion some say 120 days some say 40
days the ones who say it all happens
within 40 days based on the Hadith and
the interpretation of the Hadi of of
nowm inmm in summ making in summary in
summary in summary number one the
interpretation of the interpretation of
chronology is not consensus number two
even if you say it is it includes the
car cartilagenous models and that is
what according to this book which is an
authority that all of the doctors are
using is actually happening modification
and misog Genesis are happening at the
same time and that means to say that the
cartilagenous models are moving in the
way that the Quran says you have nowhere
to go okay so now let me now let
me okay we're just going to change we're
going let him go please now I'm going to
give him this time no one interrupt
him tell that to Mansour you told him to
come please please uh everybody make
sure that you don't won't interrupt him
because whatever he says is going to be
refuted and then we're going to move on
to the Bible where he's going to have
nowhere to run okay so guys I listened
carefully to the book that he quoted
what I heard was that bones and flesh
grow together but if you remembered when
I asked hijab to name the stages he said
and you'll see the flashback on our on
our picture on Soo films he said that
bones came before flesh he did he did
that's what he said yes so he said the
bones came before flesh and then he
quoted a book that said exactly the
opposite and he thought that I wouldn't
notice and he thought that I wouldn't
notice t t but I did notice because I
have examined this sophistry before and
I understand it
rudimentary tactic the idea is to Blind
you with lots of big sounding
words let me just let me just clarify
speak let me what let me just clarify
clarify Bob in another part of the Quran
so we read
23 um 23
12-4 we did but in 2 five in Surah 2 uh
Ayah
259 it also says exactly the same it's
towards the end of the verse if saying
there's two there two in that one
yeah right okay let me let me give the
English but you won't get what both let
let me give the English bro yeah so
that's why you need somebody still
making my point hijab it's fine bro take
your still making my point take your
time please yeah okay so in Surah
2259 it reads yeah yeah please cuz if I
get to it do you want me to help you out
with that no no I can find it thank you
it's just a case of it's not about
emology you know that let me he said now
he noticed he said it's not about
embryology okay yeah so let's actually
look at whether it talks about
embryology okay it says
this and thus we have made of you a sign
for the people look at the bones how we
bring them together and clothe them with
flesh when this was clearly shown to him
he said I know that Allah is able to do
all things no don't interrupt you
insisted that I didn't interrupt I'm
going to say everything I've got to say
you got to listen so the fact of the
matter is in two
places the Quran says bones then flesh
hijab said bones then flesh and then
quoted a book that said Flesh and Bones
grow together that's what he did and he
hoped you would wouldn't notice now he
also talked about
oif he also talked about
oif the reality is unless hijab wants to
say that he is an
embryologist it is clear from every work
of embryology that bones are not
immediately
aifi they begin as
cartilage the Quran does not mention
carage he said have you got a problem
with that when he quoted the Lexicon and
said yes I do but he insisted that he
finish all of his many many points are
you honestly telling me that Alla
doesn't have a word for cartilage when
he wants to talk about cage and he
doesn't have a word for bones when he
want to talk about B no no you're going
to listen he's losing his patience now
he want oh and look at the
interruption Cal down sorry so tell me
when you're finish yeah I'm going to but
I'm going to finish all my points like
you mentioned a lot I tried no no no
don't interrupt don't interrupt inter
stop interrupting he's mentally ins just
stop interrupting right so the reality
is and I just challenge you to check me
now do bones what what is a bone a bone
is an aifi
coage there is a reason why we have
distinct words for carage and Bones
English English English and you're
saying is Allah inaccurate in his
description English because he can't use
a word for
cartilage he uses one that could mean
cartilage and could mean bones or could
mean the two things together if he means
the two things together then it's an
error because cartilage is not bone if
it could be cartilage or could be bone
then it's an error because it should be
cartilage not bone so either way the
Quran is wrong now he said he said hijab
are you impressed at my memory of how
I've remembered all your arguments he
said what did he say how dare you a
layman in philosophy a layman in Arabic
a layman in embryology have the audacity
to stand in front of me do you all
remember him saying
that do you see he's not the only one
with a good memory let's just correct a
fact he came and stood in front of me
not the other way around but secondly
secondly he is a layman in
embryology he is a Layman on this topic
but I'll tell you someone who isn't a
layman in
embryology you're a Layman here's a
here's someone who isn't a layman in
embryology
can
Interruption so
someone who isn't a layman in
embryology is Dr P saided Meyers a human
biologist from the University of
Minnesota okay he describes the quran's
understanding of embryology as
follows vague and fuzzy and basically
stealing from
Aristotle real embo olog says about the
Quan do he know about the no why this is
the interesting point why does he say
the Karan is stealing from Aristotle why
do now personally I think he's wrong I
think there were Arab doctors at the
time who were educated in medicine but
if you listen to Aristotle's words
listen to this this is quoting
from um quoting Aristotle's work on the
parts of animals okay Aristotle lived
350 years before Christ which makes him
a thousand years before Muhammad I
thought it was 337 unless no 350 and
this is what he says stop
interrupting in the con this is
embryology According to
Aristotle listen a about the bones and
attached to them by the fibrous bonds
grow fleshy parts for the sake of which
the bones exist does that sound familiar
bones then flesh that was a common
understanding at the time of Muhammad
there is nothing miraculous about what
the Quran says and the Quran gets it
wrong thank you very much now it's my
turn to respond but I do think we should
time it by the way because we don't oh
now you want it timed no I do think so I
agree let's time it what you want 5
minutes each 5 minutes each can we get a
timer please minutes and you've got to
be willing to show your phone to both of
us on requestes are you willing to show
your phone to both of us on request okay
all right now before I actually him
get so he said 5 minutes 5 minutes each
we got
this okay go
yeah go let's read it again because I
don't think this man has good
comprehension skills he said that no he
doesn't have good comprehension this is
the problem we're dealing with someone
who can't understand he said that it
said that both of them are forming at
the same time no it doesn't say that it
says soon after the caliginous models of
the bone have been established so first
what we have cellous models of the bones
have been established yeah then it says
what the myogenic
cells which have now become myoblasts
yes aggregate to form muscle masses now
let me explain what it's saying here
it's saying that you have cartilage or
these cartilagenous
models and then you have the myoblasts
which myogenic cells which then become
myoblasts that are coming on top is that
what it says yeah everybody knows who
has done even a little bit of reading
and embryology that myoblasts are the
cells that are responsible for muscle
growth that is a fact of embryology go
to any book of embryology that you like
it is responsible for flesh so he's
saying that it's saying at the same time
no it's not it's saying first the
cellous models have been established and
then after that you have the myogenic
cells which are responsible for flesh
that are coting them exactly as the
Quran States if you want to take the
chronological reading as I've said
though that's not the only
interpretation of the Quran because
there's the fair which comes as like
which is for chronology
and or a that's not necessarily like
that that we have clothed the bone with
muscle so that's Point number one
completely and utterly refuted he said
it said and this is false it's
demonstrably false he said it said it at
the same time where is in what I read
saying the same time can you read and
understand do you understand that
myogenic cells are responsible for flesh
do you understand the alific is
responsible for bones but he said alific
continues do you know when it continues
until it continues until adulthood by
the way correct yeah so what's that got
to do with our discussion he said that
no he could have used the word or the
word for specifically for cartilage
that's not necessarily a good
description you know why because had
there been any bone that started then
that would eliminate so all the word
includes cartilage and Bone whereas the
word is cartilage only and not bone so
it would exclude the bone which would be
less specific point number three he
mentioned he mentioned now he mentioned
Aristotle Aristotle said in his
treatises that a
woman she has menstruation blood
contributes to the embryological process
I want you to find me one verse of the
Quran or one Hadith of the Prophet where
that is in fact copied if he copied from
Aristotle why is he not copying that
Aristotle also said that the baby is
formed in its entirety and then it just
gets bigger and bigger that's completely
against the Quran and the Sunnah how
comes Aristotle did not
mention where the whereby both of the
mixed fluids are there where the Prophet
Muhammad s alaihi wasallam he mentioned
the Hadith listen to this the prophet
Muhammad
mentioned that the boy or the the child
is not from the entire uh the entire
fluid meaning now what is the quranic
picture chapter number 76 verse number
two
that we have made the human being from a
a combined mixture of fluids and to test
him and we have made him hearing and
seeing so wait a minute it's saying it's
mixed and wait a minute the prophet said
it's a part of that mixed fluid not all
of it which is we know it's one cell of
the man and one cell of the woman
there's nothing like that in the Bible
at all my friend you have no chance
there's nothing like that in Aristotle's
work at all my friend there is nothing
like that in gallen's work at all my
friend and there's nothing like that in
the talmud at all my friend how did he
know this where did he get this from did
he get it from the Bible what where it
says that human being is made like Cur
cheese where it says in in Job chapter 9
verse number 6 that the the Earth is
flat and has pillars and no one no one
in the no one in the patristic listen No
One In the patristic period for 300
years not one I claim now has ever said
that the Earth is round based on the
biblical narrative everyone was a flat
earth johnos kosmus when he done his
exes of the
Bible and others and and and if you look
at origin of Alexandra he was a
spiritualist and others all of this
shows that the Bible has no way of
connecting with today and the Quran
does
there
is we can all do a shouting
match give them five minutes right
okay so ladies and gentlemen there was a
lot there again the hijab went on to say
firstly we need to establish something
that even in ancient times the Greeks
knew that the world was round
this is not something new it is an
Enlightenment myth that people in the
past thought that the world was flat and
I won't take a lecture from Muhammed
hijab about the shape of the Earth when
the Quran says that the Earth is
stretched out like a carpet oh yeah yeah
well have you ever seen a round carpet
or our carpets flat when they are
stretched out so Muhammad has just
chucked his Quran under the birth now he
went on to talk about the fact that the
Quran mentions that the child is Created
from the fluid of the woman and the
fluid of the man this is an error it is
not a fluid it is an egg it is a cell it
isn't a fluid so he has just exposed the
Quran for another error because as the
Quran says and we'll quote it and we
made the NFTA n thank you into a clot
sorry sorry here we go thereafter we
made him The Offspring as a nuta drops
of male and female sexual
discharge Now ladies and gentlemen if I
have to tell you that an egg is not a
fluid it is an egg a cell then you don't
know what a fluid is and it would appear
neither does your God but firstly it
says a drop of male fluid too too a drop
of male fluid ladies and gentlemen
contains thousands of sperms so the
Quran is also wrong there because a drop
of what we would consider a drop of
sperm has thousands of the cells of
sperms within it if not tens of
thousands but it's only one sperm that
creates the the human embryo furthermore
furthermore this idea of females
contributing to females contributing to
the Genesis of another human being is
not unique to the Quran there were other
Greek philosophers who taught embryology
who believed exactly the
same now he said what about what about
the idea of the woman's blood
contributing to the birth of a human
embryo he objected to the idea of the
menstration blood and obviously he's
right to do so but the Quran says this
then we made the nuta into a clot of
coagulated blood a clot of coagulated
blood is not what an embryo is ever a
clot of a CO coagulated blood is dead
blood it is
stopping uh based upon a cut it is
stopping rupture it is stopping bleeding
so the Quran is wrong there so now we've
got in addition to the embryology era we
also have the era that the Quran says
the World is Flat like a carpet
stretched out thank you and that is also
an error remember he condemned the
church
fathers for being flat earthers but the
Quran is a flat earther it describes the
world as being stretched out like a stop
it now he goes on to talk about the fact
that the oif he quoted his book again
and he's trying to mislead you because
that full quote do you honestly believe
that bones grow without any skin or
flesh where's the photo evidence there's
no such thing flesh and Bone grow
together notice the interruption
I'm not going to it grows at the same
time that is the conclusion of
embryologists and we've got two facts
now that the Quran gets wrong A Flat
Earth and
embryology all right uh I want to break
a news to everybody I want to break news
to everybody you know p p z Myers the
one he quoted as the embryology
Authority who said that the Earth was
inaccurate you remember that one that
sorry that the Quran is inaccurate you
remember the one he quoted
he retracted that statement one week
ago and it's on the public record that
he retracted that statement one week ago
and he said in fact I retract this point
that P's admires the person here Point
number one point number two is
this the the main point he was saying is
that the book doesn't say that the
cellous models come before the myogenic
cells form around them I've quoted it
again and there is a
chronological there is
chronological
sequential step by step which completely
negates what you're saying Point number
three there is an interpretation which
says both are happening at the same time
so all of these things you have nothing
for them I'll tell you he then talked
about the Flat Earth here's what I say
and it is a challenge to the Christian
world not just you cuz you are
insignificant you are challenged the
Christian
[Applause]
World be quiet don't inter interupt
don't
interrupt there is not one Church Father
in the first 300 years of Christianity
that ever looked at even one verse in
the Bible and concluded that the Earth
is round whereas there are scholars in
the first 300 years of Islam who looked
at the Quran itself and did uced from
that that the Earth is
round being one of them wh mentions in
and that is something that is there
being another one who quotes chapter 39:
5 chapter 39 verse 5 and listen this is
comes from the Arabic word K which means
bold be quiet my friend shut your mouth
shut your mouth my man calm down said
this Cal having said this now you're
getting excited calm down no no it's not
finished be Al be quiet here what I say
look listen to this listen to be quiet
listen now what have the Jews said about
the Bible they believed in something
called metal plate Theory look what he
said that in the midrashim which is the
ex Jesus of the Bible for how many
hundreds of years no exotical traditions
of people like Augustine when he when he
started mentioning the the round
rotundity of the earth that's a
different situation yes a church yeah
yeah but he didn't look at the Bible and
say it was round because of the earth
and if you look at John Walton who is a
Christian scholar he mentions the circle
of the earth which is mentioned in in
Isaiah 40:22 and he said but that by
consensus this means like a disc so
don't ever come to me with this I have
already told you
ibam the salaf the people and the Sal is
the first 500 years saying the Earth is
round because of the Quran not one
Church father says the Earth is round
because of the Bible respond or be
condemned okay that was brilliant
oratory I think he deserves a round of
applause that was absolutely
brilliant are we all done by the way by
the way Aller is not a mouse he's not a
mouse doesn't matter how many times you
say he's a mouse he's not a mouse akba
means Mouse so ladies and gentlemen that
was a brilliant piece of
oratory but unfortunately complete
flannel and the reason why it was
complete flannel ladies and gentlemen
why is because the church fathers were
not trying to argue that you should
become Christian because of science this
is a modernist style of argument notice
the
interruption this is a modernist style
of in of of
argumentation the early church fathers
were trying to convince people to become
Christian by using
philosophy because that was the linga
franer of education at their time and
they were good at it the reality is in
the Book of Job if you want to mine some
verse to to quote the idea of the Earth
being round in the Book of Job it says
and blessed is he who sits upon the
circle of the earth Isaiah the way no
it's in job isah in job stop
interrupting no furthermore
furthermore he said oh we've got all
these Muslim Scholars who believe that
the world is round because of the Quran
why did they even bother Pythagoras knew
the world was round before
Jesus the Greeks knew the world was
round before
Jesus it wasn't a new
thing and they didn't need a revelation
to do it either but actually let's
listen to what the Quran says about the
shape of the earth say say
it says have we not made everyone say
made the Earth as a
bed a bed is what the Quran says when
was the last time you slept on a circle
bed you sleep on a flat bed hijab not a
circle bed so yes Muslim scholars
believe that the world was round but so
did the preached a thousand years before
them thousand years before them and the
Quran says that the world is made like a
bed so stop interrupting so now coming
back to this question about OIC and
Bones so oif and Bones basically
Muhammed hijab has admitted a few things
number one he has admitted that some
Muslims do and he seems to be one of
them interpret the verses of the Quran
as sequential so I'm not misrepresenting
Islamic beliefs there are Muslims that
argue it two he has admitted that there
are alternative words for both cartilage
and bones and I need to remind you that
the reason why we call cartilage
cartilage are not bone is because they
are not the same thing they are oifc
that went really quick for 5 minutes
anyway fair enough so in terms of in
terms of
oif Allah could have used the right
terms the reality is biologists will
tell you that bones and flesh come from
the same material the
mesoderm bones and flesh come at the
same time from mesoderm and he didn't
like Dr P ERS he said that he retracted
it I'd like to see the reference I want
to see the proof because it's easy to
say retracts it I want to see the proof
but it's not just Dr pz Meers that says
this it's also Dr Joseph Nom who deiss
this dismisses chanic descriptions of
embryology as a cheap ripoff of
classical
text and Dr Joseph mum is also an
embryologist and he studied the history
of embryology so we have nothing unusual
in the Quran nothing miraculous in the
Quran the Greeks knew it
beforehand and also the Quran gets it
wrong and he's talking about patristic
fathers all right guys let me read out
he said it's job the circle of the earth
is in in the book of Isaiah as I
corrected him and told him he doesn't
want to believe me but it's there and
look at this look at what John Walton he
says this by word one of the supported
texts on this sorry he says uh uh uh so
basically here are you listening one o
uh
one of the most common examples given by
those who suggest that there is a latent
scientific consideration is Isaiah 40:22
which posits a spherical Earth this
cannot be sustained because its
terminology indicates a dis not a sphere
yeah a disc not a sphere Walton 2009
page
174 and the word use here is hug hug in
the in the Hebrew language does not mean
asphere hug in the Hebrew Language by
the consensus of those who speak by the
consensus of the midrashim by the
consensus of and all those individuals
it means a a dis not a sphere so tell me
now tell me now I want to know the
people want to know he wants to know
even this guy wants to know one verse in
the Bible which can particularly be
interpreted in a way to in any way
direct indirect indic that the rotundity
of the earth rather than the flat disc
nature of the earth which was the
consensus of the Jewish mid rasham the
consensus of all of those who have ever
looked at the Bible and and had a
cosmology because of
it that's the first point the second
point is this he keeps mentioning the
Miso I don't think he understands what
the mism is the Miso is the flesh that
comes over the the cellous models I've
explained this you can go back to the
references if you don't like it there's
another interpretation which implies
simultaneity that the bone happening at
the same time no problem there are two
interpretations number three I'm not
making the argument that all of this is
miraculous I've have not said that I
believe that the Quran speaks in a way
that everybody can understand from the
physicist to the farmer from the 7eventh
century dweller to the 21st century
man does he not know what he created and
he is the all subtle all aware
he is the all subtle and all aware yes
so Allah speaks in a way that the Bible
does not speak in that people from the
very early times the Christian Scholars
themselves were making a mockery of the
literal reading of the Bible look at
origin of Alexandria
again it doesn't matter he says this how
how look look he talks about this how he
says listen he says how could it
possibly have happened literally either
that the devil should have been LED
Jesus up to a high mountain all that his
fleshly eyes he should have shown all
the kingdoms he's saying how could he
see all the kingdoms when all the
nations were not at the foot of the
mountain that implies Flat Earth that
implies I'm telling you now defend your
Bible stop trying to think you have
something on the Quran where in the
Bible give me one person that ever
existed that said that the Earth was
round because of the words of the Bible
you said you said job and mentions hug
he mentioned this fear he mentioned the
disc of the earth John Walton who is a
scholar of Christianity says this cannot
be sustained because the word means it
is a sphere is a disc and not a sphere T
cloth my friend comes from the word
which means a ball and not something
which is flat it's over my friend how
dare you come and talk to me about
science when in Genesis chapter 5 if you
add up all the days together as have the
young eight creationists you will come
to the conclusion that the universe is
6,000 years old 6,000 years old and wait
a minute how do you know that jesis
chapter 5 has all these lineages from
Adam to his son from his son to his son
130 years 150 years add it all up like
Noel has done and you have 6,000 years
you have the audacity to talk about some
some minor thing when it comes to
embryology when you're Bible bashing
friends in America have museums and
institutions hundreds of Millions the
powers are being spent on the idea that
the universe is 6,000 years old how dare
you tell us that the universe is 6,000
years old and that all these fossils are
a conspiracy and come to me and us as
the Muslim
Community I talk about science how do
you defend yourself against the fact
that you have all these fossils all
these facts and you have your Bible
bashing mental man syndrome individuals
are believing the universe is 6,000
years old the flat Earths probably Bible
believing flat earthers this is the
reality of the situation don't ever come
here again and talk about science or
anything else because it's over and for
more information go to
ky.co UK and go to My article on the
proof of so allow me to
reply ladies and gentlemen you
ready right now you're wasting time is
it fun you don't mind wasting time
okay so where where is
this wasting right I'm so in terms of
church fathers who believe that the
Earth was round he wanted me to show him
one no no
I interrupting stop interrupting the
stop interrupting so he wanted me to
show him one eroes of Alexandria 276 to
194 calculated that the circumference of
the earth within 50 miles of its present
estimat no ladies and
gentlemen in the book in The Book of Job
in the Book of Job one of the oldest
books in the Bible historians credit the
Greeks with being the first to suggest a
spherical Earth in the 6th Century BC by
Pythagoras who suggested it how it was
known before him the round shape of our
planet is something that is was common
knowledge all the way from the time of
Jesus's time to the present that is why
Christopher Columbus went to the
Americans because they believed that the
world was
round ladies and
Gentlemen let's be clear about
something
Christian have never made a claim that
the Bible is a scientific textbook free
from error that is not a Christian
claim that is not what the Bible claims
so he's judging something by a false
standard he's timing me he's timing now
he so ladies and gentlemen time please
minut so in terms of in terms of our
time okay thank you thank you in terms
of our time ladies and gentlemen
Christians don't teach or believe that
the Bible is perfect that is a COR anic
Claim about the Quran so you have to
judge the Quran by what the Quran says
and the Bible by what the Bible says so
the Bible says it is here to teach you
about who God is and how to live it
doesn't claim to be perfect like the
Quran so when the Quran stop
interrupting stop
the Quan says what so when the Quran be
with me stop
interrupting stop
interrupting so when the Quran so when
the Quran describes the Earth like a bed
put your hand up if you think a bed is a
round ball go on put your hand
up oh
nobody not one of them hij not even
hijab wow but the Quan describes the
Earth like a bed so I'm right to say
that the Quran is in error and if the
Quran is in error according to the Quran
not me it's not from
God I need to defend the Bible in
biblical terms one minute left not in
konic terms two minutes left in konic
terms no you took time away last time in
terms of in terms of the Quran it states
facts that are wrong and I can say
according to the Quran that it is false
according to the Bible we do not make
the claims about our Bible that Muslims
make about their Quran so him coming
here and saying don't come here and say
this and say that
trying to act like the Macho Man as if
somehow this is impressive as if somehow
this is
impressive does not escape the errors in
time
have now 1 minute 20 so
I 1 minute
20 time away last time took time away
last time give him another minute please
give him another minute
give him another minute please thank you
he needs another minute so in Surah
4310 as if you were in any doubt about
what the Quran said
previous Surah
4310 it says
this who made you who made for you the
Earth like a bed like a bed and has made
for you roads therein in order find your
way like a bed believes the Earth is
flat put your hand up Muslim Muslim the
Muslims don't but the Quran does is it
describing the [__] no ladies and
gentlemen he quoted Oregon Oregon is not
a church
father he lied to you Oregon is not a
church father he's called an
ecclesiastical writer it's a Ste down
from a church father so he lied to you
when he quoted
and we Christians don't follow the
church fathers in their comments on
science all right are are you are you
with that time the time is everyone
happy with the
time I'm happy with the time let me tell
you something this verse that he keeps
bringing
this this thing about bed he keeps
saying bed bed bed Focus sorry the word
bed the word sorry means
so for example when
Maryam when she was uh when she was
talking about Jesus how he she mentioned
that term that the when he was in the
which means what cradle now really when
a woman cradles a baby she cradles it
like that like in a shaped way like that
that's Point number one point number two
the shape was not what is intended here
that what was intended
in was the comfort was that and how do
we know that in Allah says in chapter
number 67 of the
Quran that he is the one who had made
your the Earth subservient for you so
walk around its literally meaning
shoulders what are you going to say that
it means it means like the Earth is like
boxes now no it means that the the the
the mountains are referred to in that
sense go in these areas but you don't
understand imagery the point of the
matter is this before the Scientific
Revolution there were interpretations of
the
Quran that indicated the rotundity of
the earth that is nowhere to be afforded
to us in the Bible I didn't say any
Church Father I actually mentioned to
him in his in his ex Jesus against the
manans Augustine he mentions the shape
of the Earth is round you don't need
Google for that I can tell you myself
but he doesn't get mention the church I
know can you let him speak but I'm not
saying my my argument I think you've
misunderstood it was not who no Church
Father believed that the Earth is round
I'm saying no I said that they used the
Bible to indicate that that's what the
Bible was saying John Walton he mentions
in Isaiah
40:22 the word hug means a disc it
cannot be used it's the closest thing we
have but it cannot be used to indicate
the rotundity of the earth he says we
don't have to have we don't have to have
he doesn't believe in biblical inherency
by the way he might come from a more
Catholic background I don't know but
definitely a large portion of the
Christian Community probably all of
those in this park believe in biblical
inherency which is the idea that the
Bible is Flawless he is heretic in his
belief according to those no he is
according to evangelicals who believe in
biblical inherency he would be seen as a
heretic he knows that now
moreover here's the here's the point
when you first open the Bible and I say
this again when you the first thing you
see in the Bible is contradiction let me
show how that you find in a gen genis
chapter 1 The Luminaries were created
through them mystical truths may be
indicated he is saying therefore that he
has to spiritualize and allegorize the
verses of the Bible in order to keep
away from the biblical internal
contradiction it's not just the external
one but an eternal one how do we know
that because vegetation is mentioned as
happening on the fourth day in Genesis
chapter 1 but when you look at Genesis
chapter number 2 verse number 6 it said
that no plant has sprung up yet so much
so that even Scholars are saying this is
a contradiction how could you have the
vegetation on the fourth day in Genesis
1 and then and and in in in Genesis 2:6
it says no plant has sprung up yet so
were the plant's there or were the
plant's not there that's the question
what day and night thereare how can you
have day and night without the sun
you're talking nonsense how dare you
come with this to us how dare you our
clowns you're coming to us and talking
about science you got a 6,000 year old
Universe which he didn't even mentioned
he didn't even refute it he can't defend
himself he can't defend himself he had
one bullet in the gun it went astray now
he's he can't defend himself he's on
he's beneath me I'm in the mount I'm
slapping I'm punching he knows what I'm
talking about his MMA fighter one day
maybe he can challenge me
so yeah yes no problem wasting time and
so on and so forth and that's it I say
this to you today and I say to you with
all my Vigor and all the confidence he
has no answers to the rotundity problem
6,000 year problem to the Eternal
contradiction problem and I have all the
answers today so it's always true that
if you give a man like hijab enough rope
he'll hang himself and that is exactly
what he just did exactly what he just
did he
admitted a church father believed that
the Earth was rounded he just spent ages
arguing that no Church Father believed
that the Earth was round from the Bible
but then admits that Augustine did
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen is and he quote notice the
interruption again notice the
interruption pause my time pause his
time please pause his time yeah are you
done okay you done okay from the are you
ready wait he ask you from the
Bible from the
Bible listen to okay's ignorant so
Austin himself and Oregon whom he quotes
both interpret Genesis allegorically
that is the Orthodox historical use of
Genesis
it's only
fundamentalists in the 20th century that
shouted and screamed about a literal
interpretation of Genesis this is not
how the Christian fathers used Genesis
so he just shot his entire argument dead
because he evidenced the fact that the
historical use of Genesis is allegorical
and nonliteral
not literal so he's attacking the Bible
based upon a literal reading when he
admits that the church fathers don't do
that and then he says show me the church
fathers that do x y and Zed but glory to
God the holy spirit that inspired
Genesis was smarter than Oregon and
apparently M than hijab because the
reality is hijab and here's a very brief
summary of physics that a sun is a
collapsing gas
cloud before it meets the point of
nuclear fion of driving atoms together
elements together to form bigger
elements it gives off light it gives off
radiation if you were stood there before
the sun became a sun and entered into
nuclear fion you would be able to detect
its light and you would be able to
detect its heat so actually given this
fact it is true that there would have
been light in the infrared Spectrum
before there was light from a sun that
would have come later infrared Spectrum
pleas the infrared
Spectrum are you honestly telling me are
you so ignorant of physics that you
think a Sun reaches nuclear Vision
before it gives off heat go back and
pick up your gcsc study books you're
laughing at your own ignorance now that
infrared radiation ladies and gentlemen
would have been the very source of food
I do not believe that Genesis needs to
be taken literally I don't believe that
the church fathers don't believe that so
he's attacking the Bible based upon a
20th century belief that comes from
America not the historical belief of the
church he's undone his own arguments but
he believes that the Quran is perfect
the Quran describes the Earth as a bed
do you believe the Earth is a bed but
more than this here's another error in
the Quran another one until when he
reached the setting place of the sun he
found it setting in a spring of black
muddy
water put your hand up if you believe
that the sun sets in a puddle of
Mud believes that nobody not even
hijab so on one hand we don't need to
square the Bible with science in
Christianity but on the other hand the
Quran is in error even though it claims
not to be so you can stand there and do
your Macho routine and try to be the big
man but intellect
hijab you're beaten in your criticism of
my faith and the defense of your own are
you ready yeah yeah yeah listen to this
listen to this sorry it's added it's
added 53 minutes so what I want to do
is
sorry okay all right no
problem says that he says that the he's
trying to portray that the typical inter
pretation of the biblical Corpus from an
ecclesiastic and patristic perspective
the church fathers was an allegorized
understanding and there is no further
thing away from the truth as understood
by RC Hansen a known
scholar who who who wrote because of the
Bible but despite it he was an Arista
tilian and he came to that conclusion my
my uh challenge to him was to find
someone who uses the Bible and exites it
to have a spherical or rotundity of the
earth perspective number two number
three he says that he tries to imply
that origin sorry that Augustine he had
the approach of origin of Alexandria
which was an anomalous and aberrational
approach in the exical method of The
ecumenical Church fathers when actually
the truth of the matter is he actually
didn't even know that that auston who is
a fifth century scholar actually named
his exra Jesus on a Lal interpretation
of the Bible he had two he had one
called against the manans and he had one
called on the literal interpretation of
the Bible so this guy doesn't even know
his own books I know more than him on
his own books now listen to this this is
going to be a good night argument I
promise you today he will go to sleep he
will go to sleep I am getting bored okay
you will go to sleep you are going to go
to sleep just like I'm sure he has been
many times in the ring I'm going to say
this to you and I'm going to say it to
you very clearly one time celsus who was
apologist apologist he came
to origin of Alexandria what do you say
how can you have a God that died on the
cross yeah do you know how he
responded do you know how he
responded he's definitely going sleep
you know how he
responded go
ky.co and download my PDF on the truth
of Islam you'll find all the references
there he basically allegorized he said
all cannot say that all of the events
relating to the Cru to the crucifixion
are true and excuse me stop can you stop
can you stop talking yeah I know but I
can't I can't you're not even listening
to what I'm saying
Eng so listen look at me look at me
origin of Alexandria when he was asked
by celsus and this his reference in my
article on kb. co.uk he was asked what
do you say of the crucifixion what do
you say of of Jesus dying on the cross
he said it should not be seen as literal
in other words the same spiritualizing
allegorical understanding that he
employed with Genesis he employed with
the crucifixion so if you want to have
your cake you can't eat it because the
reality of the situation if you start
saying that is an allegory you might as
well say CR was allegory if you want to
use the heral principles of origin of
Alexandria it's over you want to
allegorize Genesis allegorize the
crucifixion just as origin allegorized
it just as he metaphorized it why do you
want why do you have it what's your
principle what's your principle for
allegorization why is your hermitical
principle how can you allegorize one or
not the other why on what basis who gave
you the authority
to allegorize Genesis and not allegorize
what the crucifixion origin of
Alexandria when probed by celsus he
allegorized the crucifixion meaning your
central tenants the crucifixion the
Resurrection the Ascension and so on and
so forth all of that can be allegorized
and if it is allegorized what remains of
Christianity it's all Fallen apart it's
all gone it becomes a myth just like
Hindu ISM it becomes like the Greek
mythology it becomes like anything else
so there you have it if you want to say
it's allegorized then you must
allegorize you must allegorize the
crucifixion because there is no
Authority that you may be granted
there's no Authority that you harmonical
Authority yes that you may
yes yes there's no harmonical Authority
that you have to allegorize one and not
the other and that's why it's done and
that's why you're finished and that is
why you can never stand in front of
me and you can you can have the rest of
the
time
rest I gave him an extra 55 minutes 55
seconds
so yeah should we do this
last okay is this am I speaking last is
this the last am I speaking last no you
go now I'm finish no no no want you you
you started you laid out the parameters
of sign so
I no you started you
you hij you laid out the parameters of
science first remember you laid out the
parameters you talked about the Paradigm
so you started so I have when do we
start the timing so so I have to finish
we start it from that this is the last
fine last round I'm speaking last this
is the
last we ready are we ready your last
round and after no no no this is the
last talk done after me done
finished
started are you ready right
guys ladies and gentlemen listen
carefully to the double standards that
hijab is asking you to work to he is
saying to you that you have to believe
in a literal interpretation of Genesis
why because of his quote of M origin now
he didn't actually quote origin he just
threw his name into some
statements the fact of the matter is
ladies and gentlemen origin is not a
church
father so he's quoting wrong
Source origin is called an
ecclesiastical
writer now notice that hijab wanted me
to pay attention but he's not doing it
now
so ladies and gentlemen we Christians
are not committed to a literal
interpretation of the Bible and Toto we
don't do that our church fathers didn't
do it he's admitted as much he said as
much he said that Augustine believed in
around Earth he said that so we
Christians don't need to defend every
statement of the Bible as if it was
literally
[Applause]
true now he said that the
description the origin used was literal
that there was allegorical about the
crucifixion I know origin's writings I
read origin's writings and he says that
there are layers of interpretation to
the scripture that include the literal
and go beyond the literal and he was
talking about the metaphorical symbolism
that we can pull from the crucifixion he
was not denying the historical event of
the crucifixion hijab tried to mislead
you
now the Coran on has made a number of
factually false statements
and it doesn't matter with what
bombas hijab prances around in this
little theater of ours flexing his
muscles kissing his muscles and trying
to talk about beating people up
intellectually the reality is that his
Quran has finished his religion because
his religion his Quran
that if it was from any other than
Allah I would find our errors therein I
would find
contradictions the Quran says bones
became flesh this contradicts
embryology the Quran says that the Earth
is flat this contradicts our study of
the world which is clearly
spherical the Quran states that the sun
sets in a puddle of Mud
a puddle of
Mud and it clearly doesn't set anywhere
on Earth I have found errors in the
Quran and the only way they he gets
around them is what is by saying oh well
Muslim Scholars knew better than their
Quran I agree but so did the Greeks
before Jesus know better than the Quran
he said well you're Church fathers
didn't believe in the earth as being
round from the Bible but then he showed
that those Church fathers do believe in
the circle of the earth do you honestly
believe that they would uphold the idea
of the circle of the Earth in one
hand and then as Christians say that it
contradicts the Bible of course they
wouldn't and why do they not see a
contradiction
because as the church
fathers demonstrate
consistently the reading of the Bible is
not meant to be a scientific text it
does not have to be read that way nor
does it have to be defended that way and
so his criticism of the Bible is
misplaced because it is not what we
Christians believe but he believes that
every utterance of the Quran is true and
we have demonstrated that there are
utterances of the Quran that are false
how many times does the Quran have to be
wrong time how many times does the Quran
have to be wrong okay how I'll finish on
this point then how many times does the
Quran have to be wrong before we say it
is wrong once twice three times you had
three examples today only one will do
the reality is bombastic as you are
hijab loud as you are hijab you are
intellectually scuppered because you are
trying to defend a book that makes
indefensible claims about
itself Lely talking to you
no no no we we said that we were
finishing on this talk that's let me do
one let you do one more fair enough one
more round on the
one verse says the same thing same exact
thing
[Applause]
one you want to it you you can both at
the same time it he's going to time it
he'll show you the 5 minutes let him see
the 5 minutes I'll hold it all right now
it's very important fine fine got it
okay it's important to not here the
three examples he gave number one the
embryology which we spoke about in
detail we said that there were two
readings one of them implies
simultaneity and the other one doesn't
one of them is chronology and even on
the one that talks about chronology we
talked about with references the fact
that including bones or in Arabic
language is the calig uh models which
are referred to in AR which according to
Fadi he mentions that that's included in
Bones so there's no issue here number
two he talked about the Earth as being a
me the Earth as being a me and we said
that that was used in the context of
Jesus being a baby boy in the Cradle of
his mother it doesn't signify shape but
it talks about function the function of
the earth is facilitative for the human
being it's expansive it's meant to be
from the anthropocentric
phenomenological perspective number
three we he then talked about the the
the when went to the spring now he
said he saw it he he he observed it he
found it going
into a a body spring this same
terminology is
mentioned chapter number no chapter
number 28 when the when the bird
says
this is mentioned about when the hood
hood the bird saw the woman so it's
other words it's talking about from the
perspective of the bird so here again we
talk about the perspective of it's a
it's something which is clear number two
number three so we talked about all
three points he then talked about origin
of Alexandria he was right that he is
seen as an ecclesiastic Church Father
ecclesiastic patristic writer and the
Catholic
Church the cathol yeah the Catholic
Church the Catholic Church have not put
him as a church father true that's true
that is true to say that because of
something called the origin crisis that
happened after his death in fact in the
4th Century or the fifth century so
having said that now it doesn't matter
because he actually agrees with origin's
hermeneutical method in fact all of the
other Church fathers with almost no
exception except for the alexandrian
school didn't have the approach the
origin of Alexandria and Phil and others
had so number three now we have to ask
this is he said I didn't reference it so
let me reference it right now this is
what he says origin was the crucifixion
he says the
events that have been recorded to have
happened to Jesus do not possess the
full view of the truth in mere in the
mere letter and for each event is shown
to be a symbol of something else by by
those who read the uh scripture more
intelligently this is in uh his uh his
book s CC uh chapter 2 verse number 69
is also mentioned k byh Cod at UK and go
to the article that I've written on it
for all the references having said this
now the issue is he's admitted himself
that the Bible is not free from error
and the Quran is making the point that
you can't say the book is from God if
it's not from if it's not free from
error now you have a decision to make if
you want if you want to follow a book
that is erroneous by the admission of
this man or a book which at least says
it's a it's a necessary not even a
sufficient condition for you to believe
in a book which has no errors in order
for it to be from God he doesn't uphold
the standard of biblical inherency
because he knows that's an impossible
standard for the for the Bible to
maintain and he admits candidly that the
Bible is erroneous and I may add he
didn't answer anything that I said he
didn't talk about the contradictions the
internal contradictions of the Bible
that in Origins understanding and other
people's that even the midrashim they
were confused why is it that it's
mentioned that the the the the the The
Luminaries were created on the fourth
day and that the Sun and the Moon sorry
that the night of day were created on
the first day why is it how could you
have from a scientific perspective the
plantations created on the third day and
the sun created on the fourth what kind
of photosynthesis will take place now
how can you have Plantation on the third
on the third day on Genesis chapter 1
and in Genesis 2: 6 no plant has sprung
up yet so here you have contradictions
with within the text you have
contradictions outside the text so
contradictory is it that even the
ecclesiastic church writers like origin
of Alexandria here admits it and that's
why he had to allegorize it but if you
do that then you must allegorize other
things that he also allegorized in which
case you are in a hermeneutical dilemma
and it becomes a mythological tale that
is no different from Greek myth or Hindu
myth or anything else if we start
allegorizing one thing with no precedent
or at least aberrational precedent then
we must allegorize anything we want and
that is the situation he finds himself
in okay right let me reply to this
because again and again wait are you
ready so again and again and again hijab
here creates a false dichotomy he tries
to tell you that you have to believe in
Genesis literally the early church
fathers don't teach a literal inter
interpretation of Genesis so we don't
need to defend the Bible literally and
so these problems that he's talking
about are not there because it's
dependent upon how we interpret them
don't interrupt tell me who don't
interrupt who doesn't do
pause I want to know I want to know who
doesn't apart from origin we didn't do
this to you hij you do this tactic all
the time don't you do this tactic all
the time it's just a dominating tactic
control yourself you're a trained
Fighter for crying out loud not really
is ready are you
ready ready so the fact of the matter is
the church
fathers is doing this simply strike
brother don't please please don't
engage so you right put 10 seconds back
onto my T give him 20 stop trying to do
this tactic hijab it's cheating me you
know
it right so we'll try again so the
church fathers don't teach a literal
interpretation of Genesis so he's
attacking Genesis based upon the fact
well how could the Sun be there before
plants it contradicts science when the
Book of Genesis was revealed it wasn't
revealed as a science lesson to the
Hebrew Israelites it was revealed as a
theological lesson to the Hebrew
Israelites it was teaching the Hebrew
Israelites that there is no God but one
God and he is the god of the Stars the
plants the rivers the sea the land the
birds the things that crawl and Mankind
itself that's what Genesis is really
teaching and that is how the early
church fathers interpreted
Genesis no we Christians I he said I
teach that the Bible is in error no I
don't I teach that every word of the
Bible is true properly
understood and properly understood is
not interpreting every word literally
and that is
substantiated by the earliest strata of
my writers the church fathers and he
said it was just origin no it wasn't
Augustine also did it and Augustine
wasn't from the Andrian school he was
birth in Carthage so again and again and
again hij Li and has to be
corrected and he's working on the 991
rule that 99 people will not check what
he says except one no notice he
interrupts again because this is y you
done right so the fact of the Quran say
days that the fact that Quran makes
these statements that the Earth is a bed
have you seen a spherical bed lately
stretched out as a
carpet have you seen AAL carpet
lately like a robot these things are
errors in the Quran now what will he do
he will argue that these should be
interpreted what
allegorically allegorically
that's what he will say not literally
because if we interpret the Quran
literally it's
false but if we use allegorical defense
in the Bible he says oh you can't do
that you're admitting that it's
wrong no no he misquoted origin again he
misquoted origin again misquoting means
you take part of the text out of the
text I have origin's books origin
believes in the actual crucifixion of
Jesus I know he does I've read it with
my own eyes and I will bring those books
and we'll debate whether origin believes
that Jesus was really crucified next
week and I'll show you to be a liar okay
are you up for that let me well let me
finish let me finish let me finish
because origin does believe in a literal
crucifixion but he also believes that
the imagery of the crucifixion is so
full of symbolism that you can pull
meanings beyond the literal and that's
really what origin believes so he lied
about origin he lied about the church
fathers he lied about our historical
interpretation of the Bible he lied
about the way that we read of the Bible
today and he also lied to Def Bend his
Quran misquoting embryology books to say
that bones grow without
flesh seconds so orig um are you up for
that debate next week about whether
origin believed in an actual I don't say
that origin didn't believe in it oh oh
he's changed he doesn't let me
say okay it's done now yeah it's done so
yeah well done you you actually do have
some knowledge is good because when you
came to origin according to uh Catholic
Cannon it's definitely I I know that's
the case that they didn't put him into
uh didn't because of the origin crisis
so that's well done but you did say to
everybody he was a church father I know
that was so if you knew that why did you
lie let me let me explain let me explain
explain to me why you li not every
Christian's a Catholic what well I think
you are I didn't know you were a
Catholic I'm not a Catholic all right
but I think you maybe lean in that
direction cathol uh the point of the
matter is the the the precepts you
believe in will not be universally
believed in by all Christians and you
accept that right yeah yeah so so for
example example today you argued against
biblical inherency and you know that
that's one of the Key Stone belief
systems of Evangelical Christians okay
so let me reply to that Muhammad you're
going to be really embarrassed now cuz
we have you multiple times on camera say
it one second saying to all crowd yeah
yeah that origin was a church father and
just admitted on camera that you knew
wasn't so you lied to people this is
what the da team do they Li they lie
let's say that he wasn't a church he
isn't F he's an ecclesiastical writer
right right he's an ecclesiastical
writer according to the Catholic
understanding I grant you that all of
them no no no I understand I understand
that no problem because of the origin
crisis however while say is this while
say is it's irrelevant because what I'm
saying is in the patristic period when
we say patristic period here we're
talking about he falls within that that
time and a lot of a lot of Catholic
Scholars and by the way the former Pope
I think Pope Benedict he believed belied
that he should have been a Church Father
many are in in in Catholicism are
actually saying that origin of
Alexandria should be seen as a as a
church father I'm really sympathetic to
origin yeah fair enough I like him
that's what I'm saying so uh whether
that is something that the the Catholic
Church Tak or not that's something else
origin of Alexandri in terms of his
allegorical understanding here's my
point the issue that I was trying to say
was that it's a hermeneutical principle
yes I'm not saying that he didn't or he
couldn't read him to to believe in a
actual crucifixion or an actual
Resurrection because you know RC Hansen
when he I'm I'm sure do you know who R
Hansen
is R Hansen is one of the biggest
Christian Scholars of the last 100 years
you should know who he is he he writes
against origin of Alexandria and what he
says is because one of the things that
origin does he allegorizes the the story
of the four uh judges okay and that's
because of his genocidal nature and so
on y you know this so what I'm saying is
the question that RC Hansen RPC Hansen
his full name he he puts forward is that
what what hermeneutical principle are
you using to allegorize and that's
basically it it's a bit it's a bit slap
Dash we don't know like why is he doing
this when when you said Augustine that
sometimes he does I I sympathize with
some of what you said because what you
said is although yes he he wrote two by
the way he wrote two ex of jesuses on
Genesis he wrote one called against the
manans and the other one is a literal
interpretation of Genesis and he argues
against the literal interpretation he
doesn't do either there's different
here's what I will say he literally
argues against the I know what I know
what you refer I've read this by the way
I know so you know what I'm talking I
know what you're talking about he he
doesn't despite the fact that he he
calls it a literal interpretation he
doesn't he doesn't have a consistent
literal interpretation I agree with that
thank you yeah but he's so but he is
contradistinctive to someone like origin
of Alexandria yes of course yeah so
origin of Alexandria has completely in
terms of the the spectrum of
allegorization origin would fit on the
like far right if you want to call it
that would you agree with that they they
there's definitely there's definitely
differences between Augustine and origin
but the point is I'm saying right but
the point is hijab right so the
alexandrian school for weit like in
terms of if if this is literal and this
is allegorical the alexandrian school
are here and AUST somewhere in the
middle but the point is right what we
what we've seen and the thing is you've
just you've admitted it all on camera is
that when the big crowd was around us
you were saying one thing now the
debate's over saying something else I'm
saying no no but I'm saying in front of
the crowd right here and it's I I want
to make doing this for academic
honesty wait if you want to be
academically honest what you shouldn't
be saying is that origin doesn't believe
in an actual cruci I'm not saying that
which is what you did say okay let me
let me clarify let me clarify let me
clarify let me clarify let me clarify
what he's because this is a good point
yeah whether origin believed I will
debate you next week
I don't need to
debate literal like Paul the question of
did Paul believe
in right no no but you know that there
is a discussion about that do you know
about there are discussions amongst
Heretics yes yeah fine but one man's
heretic is another man's one man's uh
you know heterodox is another man's
Orthodox Imam bukari being a perfect
example yeah exactly yeah Imam bukari
and Ahmed all of them yeah he's one
man's he's our Orthodox by his the the
considered a deviant in his own time
exactly that when we're doing when we're
doing the St of History we have to try
and be objective about these things so
what I'm saying is on this point of
origin of Alexandria my point wasn't
that he might have rejected the the the
crucifixion outright as a a literal
thing I'm saying like you
said it's all right it's just just he
justone
everything Cal when he was speaking when
he
Wasing actually
talking talking some some
respect lame go you know he does it I'm
look what I'm saying is what I quoted
when celus came to him was that when he
was and this is this is my let me make
it very clear what my postulation is
okay I don't want you to straw man
because you have a tendency to that in
this discussion today I said find
someone who looked at the Bible and then
you said then you forgot about the
second part point of what I said and you
just went with the first one I want you
to understand my argument so you can if
you want to develop Christian products
which are strong and voracious you have
to know my argument first right I heard
your argument no no but what so listen
carefully to what the argument is the
argument is not that origin of
Alexandria allegorizes everything or
that he he might not believe in the
resurrection or crucifixion what I say
is what seems to be apparent from his
works and I talked about on first
principles the Borth um translation I
have the first principles yeah Borth
look at the back of the book yeah cuz
there's like an appendix section um if
you look at that you'll find that his
approach seems to be where something is
contradictory or seemingly contradictory
he allegorizes it so what I'm saying is
he done that with Genesis and then he
done that again with the crucifixion
because when celus came to origin of
Alexandria he didn't come to me what do
you mean he didn't come to me he didn't
sort come together and have a discussion
no no no now you're being a bit
ridiculous now when they when they spoke
to each other like me and you are
speaking to each other right now right
when they spoke to each other celus is
not a Christian you know that yeah so
when he was he was doing what I'm doing
with you right now he's debating him
so origin was expected to provide an
apologetic response when he did he
allegorized so what I'm saying is where
something seems inconsistent he
allegorizes that's all I'm saying and so
therefore from our Paradigm we're saying
there shouldn't be any inconsist
inconsistencies anyway and even here's
what we're saying yeah I know I know
what you're saying so let me reply
because what you've just is admit that
my principle is accurate because I said
that you've got to judge the Quran from
within an Islamic Paradigm and you've
got to judge the Bible from within a
Christian Paradigm and the historical
Christian Paradigm is not based upon
literal Prima fascia interpretation that
is the historical continuous use of
scripture from the church fathers to the
present Church fathers today are still
doing the same thing one second you you
believe that the Quran is inherent in
all of its statements
but you never addressed the Flat Earth
and when you did address it you said you
said it was from the perspective of the
the the people so kind of the same kind
of arguments that are flat Earth that's
not the same as it's not the same as
allegorization you know that yeah yeah
but one second but one second but that
that that statement that that you've
made about from the perspective of the
birds isn't coming from the Quran that
is coming from you as an apologist
defending what the Quran is plainly
saying that's a gentic right cuz what
youve just what you've just fell into is
the genetic fality if whether I'm
offering an apologetic reply or not is
irrelevant most of your uh Church
fathers like Justin Marr was an
apologist it doesn't mean just because
he's doing that that what he's saying is
wrong so you're better than that to make
these kinds of interrogations what I say
is in terms of the perspective or the
anthropological human phenomenological
perspective that's very clear in the
Quran that that is what is intended you
know that that there's two recipients of
the Quran the human beings and Jin
so it's clearly it's going to be from
the human perspective it's not going to
be from a transcendental godly
perspective that he can see every little
thing that's not what it's meant to be
it's meant to be thing another thing is
this the point of origin of Alexandria
what I'm saying is the hermeneutical
principle is problematic because if you
say the question is here's the question
and I asked this to many people that I'm
sure you would respect who are Christian
schols in their own I said what when
where can where do we decide to stop
alizing start allegorizing so what now
the hermeneutical principle where do we
decide this is where it starts this is
where it stops what I'm saying is by the
way you said that I said that the Quran
is allegorizing I allegorize it no I
don't allegorize anything in the Quran
when it refers to it natur phenomen okay
so so so let me reply to that you said
that I was guilty of a genetic fallacy
yes and then you said that Ignatius was
an
apologist Justin Mar was an apology but
Justin Mar was also a bishop yeah okay
are you are you the equivalent Bishop
are you like
anama no it does matter because because
the thing is you're saying this as an
apologist right and you're saying this
but but you're not an AMA yeah but I'm
quoting them right so here's the thing
here is a
sing in terms of in terms of the Primal
fascia statements of the Quran there are
many that simply contradict reality and
the only way you can get around that the
only way that you can get around that
yeah yes the only way that you can get
around that is to make the Quran say
things it doesn't say which is what
you've done all the way wait wait wait
wait all the way through this discussion
so that was the first point the second
point unfortunately this guy started
screaming in my ear so I'm not sure I
remembered what you were saying um oh
yeah where where does the allegorical
start and stop right now that is done
within the Council of the church fathers
so what you do of which origin is not
one exactly exactly so your entire
argument was built on someone that isn't
even a church father let me finish it is
the it is it is the full scope of the
teaching of the church
fathers it's kind of like it's kind of
think of them like AA think of them like
a council you compare all their writings
together and where they sort of focus in
on you talking about EIC counil no no no
no I'm talking about I'm talking about
reading the church Fathers as a whole
and where they come to a consensus this
is literal this is metaphorical it falls
within a spectrum and it's the church
fathers M themselves in the reading of
them whole that decides for us what is
and what isn't and there'll always be
some that fall out of the lines this way
and fall out of the lines that way what
what I'm saying to you is that the
Islamic perspective like for example on
the mud spring thing yeah yeah what we
are we are not try why I quote uh
classical authorities from the F fourth
fifth century is to show you that the
understanding of people who are not
influenced by modern discourses was not
put in it couldn't have been because
it's we're talking about someone in the
fourth century so for example in the
case of the round earth I called right
so who who is one of the he is one of
the students of Ahmed H so he's we're
talking about 250 or something right so
he's a literalist if anything he will be
the equivalent of I don't know like I
don't know who's a a literalist but
maybe a Biblical fundamentalist yeah
maybe something like that right so he's
that so when you put it from that
perspective what I'm saying is so
therefore he couldn't have like for
instance you know the issue of the earth
sorry the Sun
there's one sh reading of abas who's a
companion of the Prophet who who put on
top of the verse of chapter number 36
verse number
40 the sun runs to her ca he reads
that he puts that in the his like his ex
Jesus the sun runs without a place of
setting yeah so he's he's now into
executing this man was um was praised by
the prophet himself he was praised he
was taught so it's unlikely that he's
going to be trying to make the Quran say
something it doesn't say do you see you
know that there are hadiths where
Muhammad repeats the claim that the
Earth sets in a puddle of Mud outside of
the Quran those hadiths are weak
Hassan the Hass no no no wa this is this
is this is the point this is I I I
believe the Hassan I've seen them
asass you talk to your Islamic scholars
I I just see no one second second all I
see is how Muslim Scholars call it some
Muslim Scholars call it Hassan you're
obviously quoting some Scholars say d
I'll have to get you next one second one
second one second no I do give it to you
that there's some that say than so I'm
not lying no you're not thank you so my
point is so my point is there are
hadiths that are Hassan right and just
for those that that don't know what is
Hassan so there's the difference between
and Hass is weak yes I know then you
have another grid which is right above
it it's called Hass
which is Hass because of another another
so there maybe two we that make and
then depending on which
scholar who wrote All I'm asking is what
is just give us the short it's referred
to as good good it's not authentic sah
is authentic I know I know authentic and
then there's a level above sah so my
point is that there are there are
hadiths that are Hassan I've seen them
label Hassan on Islamic websit right I'm
not in the I'm not in the habit of lying
about these things I know you'll get
blown up if you do you got to you got to
you got to be clear about so what we've
got is hadiths that are considered
Hassan by some Scholars and that takes
us into a whole other problem about
Hadith where Muhammad repeats the claim
that the sun sets in a puddle of Mud and
that is outside of the Quran so it's
clear that there is evidence that early
Muslims believe that their Prophet
believe that the sun set in no but the
thing is if that was true we should see
that the early exites like a
is not that early but he's like
somewhere in the 8th Century ah and
those literalists they should have taken
that view because they didn't really
care about science for instance who
Andalusian scholar he argues he argues
the Earth is flat because of he he used
the Quran to argue the okay right so he
says that it's for example not what he
didn't use what you Ed by the way he
didn't use the cuz that's not heuse yeah
I've got the ones I've got to find the
ones with a carpet I the carpet one is
not a good one to use cuz it's not the
one that the Islamic scholars Ed well
well all right I'll tell you which one
yeah tell me the best one and I'll come
back and I'll use that the thing is I
what I'm saying is no no no I'm curious
now what go tell us the he uses chapter
13 verse2 Chapter 13 Verse he doesn't
use is a weak what you were saying was
kind of weak yeah mentions uh he
stretched the Earth yeah he says
stretched it that indicates the flat the
the flatness of it right right so what
I'm saying is that these Scholars they
didn't care about scientific like right
we're let's say we're apologists or
whatever he was he didn't give a damn
like that so El Cort would mention this
kind of thing you got it yeah I'm for it
yeah so what I'm saying is where on the
literal interpretation there are two
interpretations there's one which says
it's round and one that says it's flat
so we agree that they not that that
there are Scholars that don't use
literal
interpretation say again so there are
scholars in Islam that are not using
literal on naturalistic phenomena yeah
no only no there isn't so all all Muslim
Scholars literal on the naturalistic
stuff practically all of them okay so so
we talk about the school the school and
the school and the school so even
someone
like who was a Mite he would he would
see all of those things as literal the
only ones who didn't were the
philosopher the philosopher yeah the
philosophers but they were they were not
they're not no
okay a philosopher like
I they did it so for example and a they
didn't believe in even the day of
judgment was going to be physical so I
mean day hijab it would be nice for me
and you to sit down in a place without
the crowds you know and and to have a
proper conversation cuz I'm much I much
prefer this than the shouting matches to
be honest you know I I can do as you
know I can do shouting matches all day
yeah right but but ultimately it just
becomes too confrontational this kind of
discourse is good what I'm going to
leave you cuz I I've got one question
for you me one point point one let me
make one point but what you're going to
see is in the course of our calm
conversation you undid your arguments
against the Christian faith well people
will make their own judgments yeah of
course but I I think that in the course
of our calm conversation you actually
under all the arguments you made I I
don't think so I think I just clarified
what I thought was let me tell you
something right okay what was your
question my question was this you know
you you stated that the you stated that
the um the church fathers yeah and and
tell me if you didn't state it like this
no problem but you stated that the
churchs okay that they had this
allegorized understanding of for example
they didn't expect G they didn't execute
genderist in a literal way yeah so who
are you referring to in particular um
Augustine he he would be a perfect
example he actually draws out all of the
if you take it literally all of the
obvious primer fascia contradictions in
what book are we talking about uh I'll
have to look it up cuz there's two that
I've read I'll tell you what I've read
let me explain there's I've read against
the manquin and I've read a literal
interpretation by the way a literal
interpretation is going to be hard for
you to access it's not easily you can't
get on PDF yeah I had to I had to go
around to get that book actually had to
go around to get that book and I read it
here's my here's my conclusion just let
me give you I don't think he I don't
think he does actually allegorize it
Augustine Augustine all all the church
fathers use allegory
it's most allegory is the most
consistent use of scripture in the
church fathers fine but what I'm saying
is what we talking about for example
Genesis narrative right
yeah all of the Old Testament they do it
throughout the entirety of the Old
Testament yeah know but what I'm saying
and in the New Testament but Augustine
when I read his books when I read the
his ex of Jesus on it
he doesn't seem to allegorize it at all
there's no indication of that in my
reading of Augustine he definitely he
definitely he definitely he refused
toand yeah yeah yeah he does because he
thinks he goes they think they go too
far but he definitely argues against the
idea can I tell you what he says it
definitely argues against the idea of
reading Genesis chapter 1 and chapter 2
literally he he he he basically points
out if you read it literally they
contradict one and that's the argument
that you were making yes I so you were
insisting upon a reading that is alien
to Christianity no no no but Augustine
does say that he problematizes it but he
doesn't say therefore we should
allegorize it okay we'll we'll we'll
have to look it up and see for sure but
what I'm saying is but he doesn't argue
for let me let me can I just tell you
what I read tell me what you think yeah
I read John of Kosmos yeah is that how
pronounced his name CHR chrystin yeah he
had a a um an ex Jesus of Genesis origin
had an ex Jesus of Genesis Augustine had
an ex Jesus of not all of them had it
the one origin had was more homic yeah
it wasn't it wasn't intended to be like
Augustine was not trying to it's not
homy he was trying to be uh scrupulous
and scholarly right and he's two
different things so these are the three
main ones I've read I I know other ones
have other Church fathers have commented
on it but haven't written spoken uh
examplee from that what I saw was that
origin was an outcast really from that
perspective so what I'm saying
is here's why I I don't think it's
actually a point where using him is a
problem I say because if you use him
okay what I'm saying is you said he not
normative right from your understanding
yeah he's not he's an
ecclesiastical know he he's ecclesiastic
right they have put him because of the
origin crisis right you know what Orin
crisis yeah it came in the fth century
yes yes yes so what I'm saying is is um
and I think it was harsh and unfair yeah
yeah yeah most people do most Scholars
that I've read and and that's why go
surprised with you kind of like deading
him a little bit well he he seemed to be
a very intelligent man to be honest with
you he was he seemed to be a man of
Truth you know what I was one second one
thing I read from him that you know what
I'm going to try and help you be a
better apologist because you quote
origin well I think we both shoing
ourselves yeah you you are you quote
origin a lot right and the thing is
there's no doubt that in terms of church
history he was the first Christian
writer of great scope yeah I mean the
most he he voluminous yeah he was
exactly voluminous he he he was his mind
was willing to touch everything but the
thing is just because he was the first
in great scope doesn't mean that he was
the sharpest or the best okay yeah the
thing is origin I like I I I if you look
at first principles and study it
carefully you can actually spot where he
goes off the rails in his thinking yeah
I know you can you can trace out about
the the Sun and the Moon being is it
animate or inanimate oh bro bro yeah
it's even I think it's even a bit before
that but the thing is is as you trace
out his thinking you can see it
Orthodoxy Orthodoxy Orthodoxy Orthodoxy
oh crap and then he just goes off the
rails because he makes one logical
mistake and it's about the material it's
about the attributes of God which is
inside read let me one it was the idea
about the Eternal Creator which is
something you have in Islam and an
eternal Creator means an eternal
creation let me say one Eternal material
you know one thing he said that I read
that actually made me really like him
something God great honestly do you know
what he said he he was talking about
this is in his book first principles I
read the whole thing and to the to the
back of it he was talking about these
things I was talking to you about in B
Worth's translation and he
said um we need to this is what he said
and I was so taken back by it and I
changed my mind on all the church
fathers after I read that statement I
know what you like as a Salesman hijab
so let's cut the sales he said this he
goes we need to look at the words of the
Bible carefully to discern which of it
is from God and which of it is from man
yeah and I this guy sincere and and this
is one of the reasons why he would be
considered an ecclesiastical writer as
opposed to a church father because the
Orthodox Christian position is every
part of the Bible is the word of God and
every part of the Bible is the word of
man that is exactly what we believe
about the Bible
that God's spirit no you you see you
don't youve got to listen to me I'm
listening yeah so the the Holy Spirit
has inspired every word that man has
written in the Bible but even all six
now in terms of the inherency right
because you didn't listen when I said it
in the debate so I'll say it to you now
I believe that every part of the Bible
is true did you hear that every part of
the Bible is true proper
understood which means that those parts
that are not meant to be read literally
you don't read them literally those
parts that are meant to be read
literally you do read them literally and
even on the literal bits let's just be
clear like even on the literal bits when
you consider the fact that the Bible is
a written account of people's behavior
it's not going to be as say perfect as a
camera movie of the same event it will
always miss out details there'll always
be room to fit something else in so when
I invite you to the Christian faith and
I do invite you to the Christian faith
that's the first time you said that I'm
inviting you you attacking us all so so
I'm inviting you to the Christian faith
I'm not I'm not inviting you to believe
something like Islam I'm I'm inviting
you to believe something better than
Islam I understand what you're saying
but let me tell you something right you
know you said
truth in philosophy there's different um
definitions of Truth yeah so there's for
example the consistency
um coherentism there's correspondence
theory which seems to be the most like
popular understanding and then you have
like pragmatism different types of now
what you what from what I understood
from what you've said yeah is that the
truth of the Bible is not necessarily
from a correspondence theory perspective
in the sense that when when we say
correspondence theory bertr Russell
mentions in his book problem philosophy
and others have agreed with them this is
this is probably the most popular Theory
say for
example truth is that which corresponds
with objective reality okay whereas
coherentism is it doesn't have to be
correspondent with objective reality so
long as it's internally consistent so
it's coherent here's my only issue with
it you know with the with the with the
um philosophical understandings of Truth
whether we're talking about pragmatism
all coherentism or correspondence theory
it would seem like the Bible doesn't fit
into any of that and say why because
let's say it's not correspondence yeah
so I accept we don't accept truth as
correspondence for the sake of argument
it has to be read on its terms I
understand what you're saying what we're
saying it has to be correspondence we do
believe in that right and you're
basically saying that you can't apply
that standard on us I say okay fine
except let's take a coherentism
understanding that so long as it's
internally coherent the problem is what
is there what use is there of metaphors
which contradict each other like for
example if you have if you have a
metaphor like if I speak about the
difference between validity and
soundness of an argument is that
validity could talk about something
which is coherent but not actually in
objective reality so if I say for
example a
unicorn uh done XY Z that's a coherent
story if I say a tall short man or black
and white uh sorry a black and white at
the same time or a tall short man or a
square circle that's that goes against
every definition of Truth what I'm
saying is for example in the Bible in
Genesis
surprise you but I do understand what
you're saying yeah so in in in in
Genesis when it talks about for example
that the plants were made on the third
day and on in Chapter 2 it says uh no PL
has plung up yet if even if we take this
as allegorical the issue is it's not
coherent so even if we wanted to take a
different understanding of Truth it
still fails that so let me reply cuz you
you you've actually raised what is a
very good question which to be fair to
be fair to be fair is the first time I
think I've ever heard you raise a good
question which is what is the point of
metaphors that contradict one another
this is something that is widely
discussed in Christian spirituality
because Christian theologians are
obviously aware that there are metaphors
even in Jesus's Parables that are in
contradiction the idea of being a slave
the idea of being a son how can you be
the Son and the slave of your father
that's a contradictionary metaphor and
and Christians understand the idea of
contradictory metaphor in terms of
practice the idea is that you are meant
to live in the middle of these two
contradictory metaphors not embracing
one to the neglect of the other not
embracing 50 from one and 50 from other
to make a 100 but embracing both 100%
simultaneously so the idea of using the
Son and the slave idea God is my father
I see myself as adopted into the family
of God but God is also a king he also
rules and owns me he created me and so I
must act as a son and as a subject at
exactly and identically the same time
that's a good answer let me tell you why
it's a good answer right it's a good
answer if if I would accept that if you
said that all the
biblical uh kind of direction to the end
user was what to do with their own lives
you made multiple points let me reply no
no just let me get to this point let me
tell you something no no no wait wait
wait please please before it comes to my
head man hijab hij right you all I I
also want to point out to you something
that the purpose of the in the Christian
faith is very different from the purpose
of the Quran in the Islamic faith the
purpose of the Quran is the is the nent
protogenesis of sharia it is the basis
the framework the scaffolding upon which
the Hadith put the layers that is that
am I being unfair no that's fair isn't
it right but the point of the Bible but
that's not the only point the the the
point of the Bible is that it is the
means by which we understand God and
ourselves in the world the narrative by
which we live our lives right I
understand here here's the issue right
so we have two types of injunctions
let's say or types of sentences in the
Quran for the sake of or in any speech
we have sentences which are either
commands to people telling them what to
do right and you have what you call or
narratives now I understand if even if
what you said is a little bit farfetched
that practice and you have to live
between the two metaphors I accept for
the sake of arum the issue here is when
it comes to statements about history
okay when always talk about narrative
the when the truth of the matter is
every logician on the face of the Earth
will tell you that two contradictory
things is a meaningless statement it
doesn't exist it's not real it's it's
it's worse than myth there's no um
there's no nature in which or there's no
world possible World in which what
you're saying makes sense no you you you
you misunderstood so so just on this
point right you mis the idea if God is
telling me that if God is telling me
that the plants were created on the
third day and on in Genesis 1112
whatever it was and then on in in
Genesis 2:5 he's saying no PR has spung
up here he's not telling us to be
anything here so you said it's hold he's
not telling us to be anything here he's
not telling us to be between two
practices or he's just saying two things
which contradict each other which for
all intents and purposes really you can
say is a meaningless okay let me let me
let me
rep but you're wrong you're so wrong the
point of Genesis think about Who Genesis
was revealed to it was revealed to the
free slaves of Egypt and what what were
they born into those slaves those
ignorant barbarized slaves let finish
let me finish they were born into a
polytheistic society in which there was
a God for the water and a God for the
sun and a God for the land and a God for
the plants and a God for these animals
and a God for the animals so Genesis is
telling them something it's telling them
that there is only one God and only one
Creator and he is the creator of
everything that he's created these
Bronze Age barbarized slaves were not
looking for a science lesson they were
looking for a theological lesson one
second and they get that in Genesis you
are repeating the same error that you
made in our debate you are assuming that
because we live in a modernist
scientific world that people back in the
Bronze Age were also thinking
scientifically they were not okay and so
a scientific one second a scientific
criticism of Genesis is invalid because
it wasn't written scientifically for a
scientific people okay I grant you that
here's what I said no no no I grant you
let's go with that for the sake of
argument that that it's not meant as a
scientific thing right so a scientific
criticism is invalid no what no I don't
think it is valid but I'm what I'm
saying is let's take for the sake of
argument that you can interpret the
Bible in a way which is non-scientific
allegorical defitely allegorical
definely fine no problem yeah what I'm
saying is this even on that even on that
basis okay if you do that if you look at
Genesis
1:12 where it says that the plants had
been made on the third day and look at
Genesis 2:5 it said no plan has sprung
up yet here this particular specificity
I'm not talking about the entire what
the The Motif or the theme of Genesis
this is contradictory so I am left to
assume that it's false now even on a
coherentist understanding of Truth not a
correspondence understanding I'm not
saying it has to correspond with
objective reality I'm saying even on the
coherent this
understanding there's no need for that
to be the case now what I'm saying is
this the Quran is it's not saying when
it
says if this was some other than God
they would have found in it many
contradictions what it's saying is that
it's the principle of sufficient and
necessary conditions now the truth the
matter is in our logical day-to-day life
we we require a certain level of there's
an evidentiary bar that is required in
order for us to come to a conclusion
about things if that evident bar is not
met then we can't we can't believe in
those things how can I be punished for
disbelieving in contradictory statements
so let me let me address that point let
me address that point because once again
you've demonstrated what all your da
mates do Ali da shami I know he's not
your mate I know he's not your mate
Hashim manso you all all make this
cartoonish characterization of
Christianity and then you attack it if
you had actually taken the time to read
Genesis 1 and Genesis 2 you would see
that what they are communicating is
different Genesis one is talking about
the creation of world and everything in
it Genesis 2 is talking about man's
place in the world so it's talking about
the creation from the theological
perspective of the importance of mankind
so the chronology is not actually
important because the teaching
theologically is different one second
let let me finish let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me finish let
me finish you should also know that
there's plenty of Christians that do
harmonizations between these things you
should know that I know so so the fact
most of them so the because most of them
recognize that literary from a literary
point of view you don't need to because
it's buying into a modernist myth
which is this idea that we should judge
ancient literature by a
scientific one second by a scientific
Paradigm of today and that is a
historical now let's come back to the
Quran because the Quran you didn't
answer what I said but the
Quran no no no the Quran the Quran as
we've demonstrated in our discussion
make statements that are factually false
they do not correspond to reality no but
that's what you're saying what I'm
saying is that look can I can I just
come back on this yeah we have to
understand okay you you keep saying this
if you want to be a serious apologist
that's more than just like a
propagandist you need to kind of listen
to what I'm saying a little bit here
everyone knows that I've just told you
this the literal interpretation of the
Quran is understood by the language what
the language can facilitate for example
you mentioned yeah has three meanings in
the Arabic language in fact the word is
used in other places in the Quran that's
the one about the leech and uh yeah yeah
the clinging and stuff yeah the clinging
you know it's
mentioned when it talks about when you
have more than one wife don't leave
don't go to one and leave the other one
hanging suspended now that that would be
metaphorical wouldn't it of course it is
yeah yeah I believe in metaphor in the
Quran right and we're not saying we
don't believe in metaphoric language
what we're saying is when you
metaphorize things which are not
intended to be metaphorized that's where
the problems come here's what I'm saying
is going back to the Met fors that
contradict each other so are you happy
to say that it's iology it's um myth
that Genesis is myth I I am happy to say
that a literal reading of Genesis is not
what is meant to be understood is it
myth yeah if so long as we don't do a
false equivalence that myth means false
no I'm not saying that I believe that
the mythology of Genesis yes is
completely true I know that I know I I
believe every word of Genesis I know
that yeah you're saying that so you
believe that genes is a myth but you you
you're depending on some kind of
coherent understanding of Truth what I'm
saying is the problem is even this even
a myth which contradicts itself is
useless no it's meaningless because
you're asserting a contradiction based
on a prima fascia literal reading and I
keep telling you that the Prima fascia
literal reading is not how you're
supposed to read Genesis so okay you
know what it says no PL has sprung up
yet yeah what does that mean So it's
talking what let's look at that entire
chapter because bad da is taking verses
out of their context right so the
Genesis story in chapter 2 is talking
ultimately about the creation of man and
the importance of man to Creation that
man is the priest of God in creation
that he's meant to be God's
representative on Earth in creation care
and to cultivate that's the story of
Genesis what I would say to you though
can I say you mention modernism right
can I one second second one second one
second but the the the reality is the
reality is if you assert that the Quran
when it for instance talks about the the
the the the the idea of the the blood
yeah yeah but I'm saying blood is not
the only thing right but the point is
that's factually false what are you
saying I'm say saying that an embryo is
not a blood CL are you are you arguing
that an embo is a blood let me let me
tell you what I said right the word is
yes what does mean it's been translated
as blood clock it can be translated
blood but there's three translations it
literally translates I bro you have to
you have to listen to what I'm saying
I've done a whole series on this right
you can check on sapan Institute what
I'm saying is this is that one of the
words I've just told you it means to
suspend and I just gave you an example
in the Quran that
will
so if you have two wives three or four
don't go to one and then just leave the
other one like that so you leave her
suspended so are you saying this is
metaphor what no it's not metaphor not
so it's not metaphor you're not
understanding what I'm saying so when it
says so when it says let him carry on he
said three point then we made the nuta
into a clot okay good is that accurate
or inaccurate yeah it's accurate so you
actually believe that an embryo is a
blood clot hold on hold on culated blood
just jump on another you're going on to
another Point what I'm saying is that
you're saying is bad da you've already
referred to the Gen account as a myth
I'm explaining to you you say that like
it's a bad thing
not all right let's finish now finish
right what I'm saying is even if you
understand yeah oh careful careful
careful it's going to break
man bro man be careful that's going to
fall and
break there's a
the where he
said he said that there are two things
two bloods which are prohibited two
bloods he
said and uh uh the spleen and the lung
and the liver yeah now in Arabic Lang
you have to understand this because if
you don't get this you won you will not
improve your your apolog that's it you
you I'm happy to let people listen the
prophet referred to the spleen and the
uh the liver has two bloods okay even
though there's not blood there they're
not blood it's not blood so what it is
is that the Arab custom is that you
describe something by how it
looks do you understand this I'm hearing
and this is an Evidence because that the
prophet said two blood and it wasn't
actually blood actually blood it was the
liver and the spleen so when the Quran
States it's even the the the translation
which says blood clock it doesn't mean
by composition it means by aesthetic
value do you understand this I hear that
okay good now that's why I'm saying
there's three uh primary meanings one of
them means that one of them means
something which clings other thing means
something
which more microphones than you no
matter how you are you just going to
fall over and not falling into me so so
so the point is the translation that we
have from Muslim scholars in Saudi
Arabia they have chosen clot they have
chosen CL they they have chosen CL right
they have chosen clot and that is
scientifically inaccurate fact fine my
friend is a transl of the Quan one
second one second
know to listen you reality
reality is that that when you when all
you did is just make your profit look
worse because you you said that your
prophit described things as blood that
are not blood in the so so my point to
you is this is just more evidence that
your Prophet was not Guided by God
thanks but that's not that's not what
the is we're going to stop it's lovely
to talk to just to show how much I
appreciated a calm conversation if you
read it or not he enti
will I want to give you yeah he read
like not two P
pamphlets I know I know this I
know have a have a read that's my gift
to you I appreciate you taking the time
to talk to since you gave me a gift yeah
[__] let me give you a gift I will
definitely take a [__] I'll give you a
gift as well this is a pen it's it's a
pen I
like enough thank you very much I AC it
czy
all right you look up
your